as more and more Americans move outside
Authority z' debate how to crack down
george w bush releases a cove at 19
video and Joe Biden continues to
struggle with Tara Reid sexual assault
allegation i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protects your data from prying eyes and
express it VPN dot-com slash man alright
well may the fourth be with you and
quick note on that let's just all hope
that one day Disney will stop taking all
the nostalgia we have for what was one
of the great intellectual property
pieces in the history of Hollywood and
using all that nostalgia nor to
promulgate social justice warrior
bullcrap that will be the day when they
can stop blaming their toxic fandom
because the reality is Star Wars is
fantastic my son loved Star Wars my
daughter loves Star Wars missins
birthday is this week we're having a
Star Wars theme party you know who's not
gonna appear at that party anyone from
the new Star Wars series will be all the
originals cuz that's all he cares about
all he cares about you know I thought
the originals are good and everything
else blows and you know why that is
because they used to care about the
story in Hollywood already well now to
the actual news of the day so over the
weekend the president of United States
President Trump he did a he did a town
hall event with Fox News at the Lincoln
Memorial's pretty stunning backdrop
actually and there are a couple of big
headlines that came out of this headline
number one is that President Trump
revised upward his estimate of the
number of deaths from corona virus to up
to a hundred thousand he is not wrong
about this obviously we will probably
hit a hundred thousand over the course
of the year we already have about
seventy thousand a little bit under
seventy thousand I saw a rumor going
around last night that the CDC had
revised downward their estimate by half
that's not true
the CDC data was not taking into account
the last couple of weeks because they
were just relying on number of actual
reported deaths as opposed to the number
of estimated deaths those tend to come
in over the course of the next couple of
weeks so we are currently at about sixty
five thousand sixty-six thousand dead in
the United States the virus will kill
somewhere between 75 and a hundred
thousand President Trump is correct
about this this was the original
estimate that dr. Burks put out and that
Anthony thought you put out from the IH
m e model it suggested it could be as
high as a quarter of a million and we
will end up somewhere in that range in
all likelihood here as president Trump
acknowledging that and also
acknowledging that the steps taken by
the government have actually prevented
this from being a lot higher we're gonna
lose anywhere from seventy five eighty
to a hundred thousand people that's a
horrible thing we should lose one person
over this this should have been stopped
in China it should have been stopped but
if we didn't do it the
we would have lost as a million to a
million four million five that's the
minimum we would have lost probably
higher than it's possible higher than
two point two okay one of the big
questions here is whether that is
because the health care system would
have been swamped and it would have
looked like Italy because even Italy
didn't end up with those kinds of
numbers or whether the only thing
preventing us from hitting that one
point five two point two million is the
fact that we are locked down in which
case the letting up of the lock down is
going to lead to a dramatic spike in
cases so either the modelling is
somewhat wrong or we have basically
acknowledged that we're not going to end
up between 100 and 240,000 see this is
sort of the problem here is that what
the models suggested is that even with
social distancing we would end up
between 100 and 240,000 in most states
have really not completely released
their population even in states like
Georgia or Colorado which have started
to release their population people
aren't crowding into movie theaters
people are still wearing masks people
are social distancing and one of the
things that's fascinating is that it's
unclear what exactly we're aiming for at
this point what exactly are we aiming
for are we stalling for time or trying
to play for time so that there are new
therapeutics that are brought to bear or
so that a vaccine is developed or are we
basically doing this Whedon thing and
aiming for hurt immunity because Sweden
continues to approach hurt immunity in
places like Stockholm we already know
that according to the antibody tests
well over a quarter of the people in New
York City have had kovin 19 which means
that they're kind of getting to the
point where herd immunity is is not that
far off right now there's a lot of death
till you get to herd immunity is sort of
the idea but even there the real
question is how much death is necessary
for a herd immunity if you can segment
off the populations that are most
vulnerable meaning that if you actually
look at the stats in various areas
around the world what you see is that
anywhere from 40 to 50 percent of all
deaths in places like Italy in places
like Sweden in places like another ones
are happening in old-age homes in the
United States that number is anywhere
from 20 25 to 40 percent so if you were
actually able to protect those places if
you were able to test all the people
going into those places if you were able
to restrict the movement to people or
inside the old-age homes then you could
immediately remove presumably about 25
to 30 percent of that entire death toll
from the rolls which starts to make this
look a lot less deadly for the rest of
the population particularly under age 60
if you're under age 60 the chances that
you're going to die from this thing are
very low unless you have a serious
pre-existing condition like diabetes and
if you're under the age of 40 there's
almost no chance that you die from this
thing or even sustained
is damage from this thing statistically
speaking so the question is what we are
aiming for I'm gonna get to that in just
a moment cuz President Trump it's not
clear whether we are just waiting for a
vaccine to be developed or whether we
think that therapeutics will be like
what is the change where is the
game-changer here and if there is no
game-changer then nature will have her
course the only question is how long it
takes for nature to have her course and
if nothing changes then either a lot of
people die over the course of a longer
period of time or a lot of people die
now or if those are the two choices and
neither one of them is very good we're
gonna get two more of this in just one
second first I need to take a moment to
give a shout out to all of our
advertising partners who helped make the
show possible obviously there's a rough
economic times and they rely on you to
continue patronizing them and we rely on
them to continue advertising on the
program to ensure that this show can
continue to be brought to you we are
super grateful for our advertising
partners I love all of the products that
we sponsor on this show and all of our
advertisers we're all trying to get
through this together and we really
appreciate you patronizing our
advertising partners speaking of which
one of my favorite advertising partners
my friends over at the pearl source so
mom's Day is coming up
Mother's Day is coming up and let me
just tell you the pearl source this is
fantastic stuff jewelry is one of the
most popular gifts you can get from
Mother's Day and there's an excellent
reason for it you can rarely go wrong
especially if you're going with the
classics there's nothing more classic
and timeless and fine pearl jewelry
which doesn't need to break your budget
at the pearl source you get the highest
quality pearl jewelry jewelry and up to
70% off retail prices why because pearl
source cuts out the middleman they
eliminate traditional five-times markups
by jewelry stores and are selling
directly to you the consumer your local
jewelry store is closed also so you can
shop safely and securely from the
comfort of your home Mother's Day is
next Sunday so you really have no time
pearl source offers fast and free
two-day shipping on every order zero
contact delivery everything comes
beautifully packaged into elegant
jewelry box listen I have jewelry from a
jewelry source from pearl source for my
wife just beautiful beautiful stuff also
I know personally the people who own the
pearl source is a fantastic family-owned
company really really great people I
would trust them to watch my kids not
just to sell me jewelry has your mom
been quarantine you at home for the past
month show her that you still remember
where she lives by sending her jewelry
from the pearl source for a limited time
listeners to my show can take 20% off
your entire order for Mother's Day go to
the pearl source com /ban enter promo
code been at checkout for 20% off your
entire order great
the pearl source com backslash Ben also
if you're not sure that she's gonna love
it the pearl source comes in a no-hassle
60 day money-back guarantee so it's
risk-free as well the pearl source com
backslash pen enter promo code Ben at
checkout really a great gift for Mom go
check them out right now the Pearl
source.com
backslash Ben enter promo code Bennett
check out for 20% off your entire order
okay so the president says that he's
confident we'll have a vaccine by year's
end he's been engaged in a in a grand
attempt to accelerate progress toward a
vaccine here is the president we are
very confident we're going to have a
vaccine at the end of the year by the
end of the year have a vaccine by the
end of this we think we're going to have
a vaccine by the end of this year and
we're pushing very hard you know we're
building supply lines now we don't even
have the final vaccine Johnson and
Johnson if you look at Johnson & Johnson
is doing it we have many companies or I
think close because I meet with the
heads of them and I find it a very
interesting subject because it's so
important okay so if we're betting on
the vaccine by the end of the year then
presumably the goal is that we continue
social distancing we continue wearing
masks herd immunity is is not something
that we aim for because obviously once
the vaccine arrives then we can
artificially create herd immunity I mean
it's effectively what a vaccine does it
artificially creates herd immunity that
would normally happen through a diseases
natural progression through the
population you keep as many people alive
as you can until then you vaccinated all
the people who are capable of getting
the vaccination and then you move on
with your life because that's the best
you're going to do so hopes for the
vaccine are actually maybe balancing
against a wider opening up right if you
if you think of AK scene is not gonna be
developed for five years here then you
may as well say have at it right you may
as well say okay here's what we're gonna
do we're just going to protect the most
vulnerable populations we're gonna tell
them to stay at home we're gonna aim for
hurt immunity with the rest of the
population and go out and willy-nilly
have fun in fact there are some
scientists who are suggesting exactly
that but we'll get to that in just a
minute but what's really fascinating
about all of this is the imagistic s--
of the whole situation the imagistic of
the whole situation are really
interesting so president Trump's actions
as I've said from the beginning have
been pretty good I mean once the once
the feds got serious about this they got
really serious there was no ventilator
shortage I mentioned this last week
everybody was talking ventilators
ventilators vents there was no
ventilator shortage there's talk about
overwhelming the medical system didn't
happen there was talk about the federal
government not
people what they need didn't happen in
fact every major Democratic governor in
America has come out and said that the
federal government did what they were
supposed to do and getting people what
they wanted that's not stopping Joe
Biden from claiming however that Donald
Trump blew this in dramatic fashion even
though Joe Biden has no evidence that
Donald Trump actually blew this in
dramatic fashion this has led Joe Biden
to putting out an ad he has to run on
the back of the pandemic because the
fact is that before the pandemic Joe
Biden was probably going to lose before
the Pens I met Joe Biden was in serious
trouble because the economy it was quite
good because Donald Trump remains
popular in a lot of those swing states
more popular than he is in the country
at large now Joe Biden is jumping on the
pandemic really to attack Trump and this
is why image matters the buck stops here
Harry Truman said it it means no excuses
it means taking responsibility the
ultimate responsibility for the biggest
decisions in the world every great
president has lived up to it but Donald
Trump yeah no I don't take
responsibility at all first of all the
governors are supposed to be doing a lot
of this work and they we're back up
without an ordering clerk we're back up
Donald Trump thought the job was about
tweets and rallies and big parades he
never thought he'd have to protect an
early 330
okay so that's Biden's dad here's the
thing when it comes to shifting blame
the Obama administration was bar none
the best at this they were incredible at
this how many people went under the bus
in the Obama administration I mean that
bus we just speed bump its own staff
regularly I mean the number of heads of
departments who ended up going under
that bus very Kathleen Sebelius at HHS
was one of the people who ended up under
the bus Lois Lerner at the IRS ended up
under the bus
lots of people ended up under that bus
Joe Biden not famous for taking
responsibility famous for stealing other
people's verbiage and from to make
speeches but not particularly famous for
taking responsibility nonetheless the
the push by the Democrats and by the
media is going to be the president Trump
is too volatile to lead now the reality
is again that Trump's actions in the
pandemic the actions have actually been
okay it's the messaging that's been a
problem and here's a perfect example of
this so Andrew Cuomo has about seventy
seven percent popularity in New York
he's been horrible I mean really
horrible his leadership has been
terrible he did not shut down the subway
system if you're gonna lock this thing
down you gotta shut down the subway
system he didn't do it Andrew Cuomo did
not even bother to shut down the subway
system overnight for disinfecting until
last week Andrew Cuomo had a rule in
place in New York that if a person in an
old-age home went and was diagnosed with
Koba 19 they were had they had to be let
back into the old-age home which is
basically a recipe for infecting
everybody and killing everybody Andrew
Cuomo didn't lock down the state until
late March Andrew Cuomo spent all of his
time on TV whining about how he wasn't
getting ventilators rather than
presumably changing the rules that he
could protect more of a citizenry
meanwhile Bill DeBlasio in New York
horrible mayor Wright spent the weekend
ripping on the Jews meanwhile people
were out at the parks on mass right but
nonetheless Andrew Cuomo's popularity is
like 77 percent including 53% of
Republicans why because the Andrew Cuomo
understands the image here which is I
take this seriously so Andrew Cuomo over
the weekend for example he went out and
he personally disinfected trains he was
out there personally disinfecting the
trains okay wow what a hero what a hero
you know this sort of kind of political
posturing is really dumb I remember that
Barack Obama used to do this every time
there was some sort of natural disaster
he would jet in and then he would take
the helicopter to the natural disaster
there'd be pictures of him looking out
over the natural disaster and this meant
that he cared a lot a lot a lot
well now Andrew Cuomo who
shut down the subways originally because
the subways were the chief spreading
point for the virus now he's out there
and they're pictures of him disinfecting
because he cares so much he cares okay
so he understands the game the game a
listen this is the thing about Trump
Trump says the game doesn't exist the
game is dumb he is not wrong about this
all right this is one of the things that
people actually on his side kind of like
about Trump is the fact that he just
says the game is stupid and I'm not
gonna play it but the reality is that
most people are susceptible to the game
Cuomo knows this which is why he's out
there doing this sort of thing it's also
why it's damaging for Trump to get
volatile with regard to sort of unifying
messages so George W Bush put out a
message over the weekend there was sort
of a unifying message for the country
that's not a bad thing he's the
ex-president of the United States and
Trump promptly just crapped all over him
which again is that a great look in the
middle of a time when we need unity no
it isn't and that again is Trump
fundamentally misunderstanding what his
job is to do right now politically
speaking he understands his job when it
comes to trying to secure the American
people it's actually precisely the
reverse of the Obama administration when
it came to keeping the American people
safe the Obama administration was not
very good at keeping the Americans
people safe particularly when it came to
foreign policy when it came to pandemics
the they never had to face anything like
this nobody's had to face anything like
this for a hundred years in the United
States but when it came to foreign
policy the Obama administration was
constantly leading from behind shifting
responsibility not doing the things that
were necessary to keep the American
people safe and then posturing about it
Trump shockingly is actually quite bad
at the posturing but the policy is
actually quite good we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that Mother's Day is coming up
and you have a chance to get your mom
the best bouquet available in the past
waiting until the last minute to order a
Mother's Day bouquet from 1-800 flowers
that might have worked out fine this
year is a bit different because there is
limited delivery because the system has
been basically overwhelmed it's
important to lock in your bouquet order
right now right now the 1-800 flowers
has beautiful Mother's Day gifts
bouquets and range mints and a great way
to make every mom feel loved when it
matters most whether it's roses lilies
daisies or problems all blooms from
1-800 flowers are picked at their peak
shipped overnight to ensure freshness
and her amazement they last forever I
mean these things last a long time you
going to pick up some flowers from the
grocery store which mom can't even go to
anymore because it's coming and those
things will wilt fairly quickly you get
the 1-800 flowers stuff that stuff lasts
a long time
1-800 flowers is committed to safety of
they're team members and your family so
all deliveries are contactless picking
an early delivery date ensures your
bouquet will arrive in time to make
mom's day special with limited delivery
you need to lock in your order right now
hurry and order before Friday don't put
it off order today from the official
florist of Mother's Day 1-800 flowers
back on let me tell you their stuff is
great every time I used to go out of
town when travel was still a thing we
did in this country I would send my wife
1-800 flowers I'm probably gonna do it
again for mother's day to order Mother's
Day gifts bouquet or arrangements go to
1-800 flowers calm Shapiro's order today
save that 1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro's
that's 1-800 flowers calm / appear oh go
check them out right now that is a great
gift okay so trump misunderstanding sort
of the imagistic of all of this here's
president george w bush giving a a
statement in which he calls for unity
and then you'll see how Trump responded
we cannot allow physical separation to
become emotional isolation this requires
us to be not only compassionate but
creative in our outreach let us remember
how small our differences are in the
face of this shared threat in the final
analysis we are not partisan combatants
we're human beings equally vulnerable
and equally wonderful in the sight of
God we rise or fall together and we are
determined to rise okay so that that is
Bush fundamentally understanding the
kind of stuff Americans want to hear and
then from the immediately takes the
opportunity to your smack bush which is
that like how exactly is this useful he
tweeted out Pete headsets oh by the way
I appreciate the message from former
President Bush but where was he during
impeachment calling for putting
partisanship aside he was nowhere to be
found and speaking up against the
greatest hoax in American history not
everything is about you dude not
everything is about you and that kind of
that that kind of narcissism does not
serve President Trump well in the middle
of a pandemic it just doesn't most
Americans don't want to hear that stuff
they don't know again that is Trump not
getting the imagistic part of the job
correct but here's the thing about Trump
he is getting a lot of the substance
right okay so President Trump has a gut
feel that Americans want to get back to
work and he is correct about this so
President Trump over the weekend he said
listen people want to go back you see it
in the protests more than seeing in the
protests you see it in the number of
cars on the road seriously you want you
want a better gauge for how many people
want to go back to work than the
protests all you have to do is drive
around
the freeways in Los Angeles on a weekday
traffic is up like 25 to 30 percent it
used to be that you could really just
speed through LA you'll actually hit
traffic jams on occasion during weekdays
in LA is still technically shut down
there's president Trump saying people do
want to go back he is correct about this
there I don't honestly I don't
understand how this has become a
partisan issue this should be a
data-driven issue somehow this has
become a partisan issue I think I have
an inkling as to why it has become a
partisan issue and that is because as
I've said before there is there's a part
of the of the hard left
that sees this crisis as an opportunity
and speaks out openly about that Hillary
Clinton said this crisis is an
opportunity and the longer you walk down
the more of a crisis it becomes
economically which requires the
government to step in so for folks on
the left for folks on the right they're
a bunch of countervailing interest that
have to be balanced here one is how do
we what is our exact policy here with
regard to saving lives and flattening
the curve are we aiming for hurt
immunity are we not aiming for herd
immunity how do we protect people who
are most vulnerable how do we allow
people who want to go back to work to go
back to work also how much economic
damage can we take before the damage
becomes essentially irreparable and you
have tens of millions of people who are
for all intents and purposes on
long-term unemployment insurance for
Democrats those questions just don't
exist in the same way because the idea
is well you know if we lock down forever
and that's obviously the way that we
saved the most lives in the immediate
term sure more people may commit suicide
to them of jobs sure more people might
lose their life savings sure more people
might not have homes sure more people
might not be able to to sustain their
businesses but that's where the
government steps in and so it's a
win-win because we wanted the
government's to step in in the first
place as we will see this is an actual
agenda item for many Democrats right now
which is why a lot of Republicans are
like okay so I think that you have a
separate agenda here this isn't your
agenda here is not actually about saving
the maximum number of lives your actual
agenda is changing the underlying
political dynamics of the situation when
you lose faith in the law that's when
you start to see people disobeying the
law right here's President Trump
explaining people do want to go out and
you see it in the protests I think you
can really have it both ways I think a
lot of people want to go back they just
want to go back you see it everyday you
see demonstrations all over the country
and those are meaningful demonstrations
oh it's big stuff but you also have some
people that are very scared
probably everybody scare
when you get right down to it it's a
terrible thing a terrible thing that
happened to our country okay what are
you saying there is obviously correct
but the question becomes how scared are
people not to go out people are going
out okay the reality is not to protest
the reality is many many Americans are
leaving their homes many Americans are
leaving their homes in fact by data
provided to NPR by a mobile phone
location data company called safe graph
based on the locations of about 18
million mobile phones across the country
NPR's analysis determined the percentage
of cellphones that did not leave their
home location daily in every u.s. county
it has been dropping steadily since the
middle of April and it is dropping
precipitously now about 50% of mobile
phones that safe graph had data on
stayed home on April 12 which was Easter
that number hasn't come down since that
number hasn't since come anywhere close
showing a steady decline with the most
recent numbers showing that less than
40% stayed home on April 27th the trend
is consistent across the entire country
it's for all the talk about its red
states and these red straight idiots
were going out and dangerous it's it's
true everywhere you should have seen the
pictures from New York yesterday have
you seen some of the pictures from New
York I mean they're insane the pictures
from New York of people who are not even
close to social distancing in the middle
of lawns in New York City like blanketed
with human beings by the way not the
Hasidim okay people who are shirtless in
the Sun in New York City two feet away
from each other
that is not Bill de Blasio may be deeply
concerned only about the custom it turns
out there are tons of people in New York
who have not been socially distancing
bill de blasio hover is so concerned
about the Hasidim here she sent the NYPD
to break up study sessions where people
were socially distancing and wearing
masks which is always a great look over
there the bottom line though is that
metrics are showing that people are
getting out of their house a lot more a
lot more when you take a look for
example at Arlington Virginia on April
20th nearly half of cellphones safe
craft provided data for we're staying at
home over the next couple days the
number two clients one-third as low as
it was during the middle of March okay
so so people are beginning to say you
know what we're basically done with this
we're basically done and as time
increases and as the number of headlines
coming out of New York decreases you are
going to see an increasing push to open
things back up and open open things up
in pretty serious ways president Trump
understands this he understands this
said innate level and Frank
he should understand this because this
is not sustainable folks on the left may
want it to be sustainable as we'll see
in a second but it is in fact not
sustainable so the question becomes what
exactly are we aiming for what exactly
is the goal here so you have deborah
birx suggesting the protesting without
social distancing is worrisome because
you're going to get a broader spread and
then we have to keep being vigilant and
she's she's right about this depending
on what we're aiming for here's dr.
deborah birx it's devastatingly
worrisome to me personally because if
they go home and affect their
grandmother or their grandfather who has
a comorbid condition and they have a
serious or very or an unfortunate
outcome they will feel guilty for the
rest of our lives so we need to protect
each other at the same time we're
voicing our discontent ok so again she's
not wrong about this but the question
becomes and I said this now several
times what exactly are we aiming for so
here's the debate the debate is between
dr. Scott Atlas who is a professor over
at Hoover Institute at Stanford
University and between a historian who
is who has written a book about this
pandemic the historians name is John
Berry and I will give you the debate in
one second because this is the next
stage of the debate that people don't
want to talk about but we're going to
have to talk about so we're gonna get to
that in just one moment first let us
talk about a great great gift you can
get for your parents for Mother's Day
I'm talking about maybe those important
thing you can get them preservation of
their memories so out in their garage
right now are a bunch of old film reels
that are just rotting away a bunch of
old VHS tapes you own a VCR they haven't
accessed those tapes in years but you
can make all of that accessible right
now what could be better than making all
of those memories available to mom and
dad in a digital format you can watch
them with mom and dad even in a social
distance it's just fantastic and this is
what legacy box does you go into that
garage you pick up all that stuff you
put in a box you dump it in the box you
send it to legacy box legacy box sends
it back to you digitally preserved
copies on a thumb drive DVD or the cloud
ready to watch share and enjoy mmm
plus they keep you up to date with
regular email updates throughout the
digitizing process legacy box is the
world's largest digitizer of home movies
and photos they've helped over 750,000
families digitally preserve their past
rediscover your glory days by digitizing
these a reparable oh you're
irreplaceable heirlooms with
legacy box when the favorite kid award
this Mother's Day give mom a present she
will not forget for a limited time
legacy box is running a 50% off Mother's
Day special that is a great deal for
again maybe the most important gift you
will ever get mom is preservation of all
of those memories legacy box it's
perfect for you for someone you love
I've been doing it with my own parents
it's fan-freaking-tastic it's great go
to legacy box comm slash men save 50%
while supplies last that is legacy
voxcom slash men save 50% well supplies
last okay so what exactly are we aiming
for is the big question John Berry is
the author of a book called the great
influence of the story of the deadliest
pandemic in history and he wrote a piece
called will warm weather slow
coronavirus from the New York Times and
the answer is maybe but we actually
don't know because the fact is that so
much of the population has not actually
been exposed to koruna virus he says
modelers estimate estimate that the true
number of infected persons is up to 20
times the reported number which still
leaves about 95% of the population
susceptible if as in 1918 susceptibility
proves more important than seasonal
influences hot weather will not give as
much relief relief as hoped for by the
same token that would mean the expected
seasonal surge when colder weather
arrives might not be as large as feared
in other words more people will get it
now and less people will be will be
available to get it later basically
because many people have had it also
copa90 mutates much more slowly than
influenza and its key spike protein the
part of the virus that attaches to cell
seems particularly stable amid all of
the bad news that this virus has brought
this characteristic of the viruses is
silver lining it in several ways
this reduces almost zero the chance will
become more virulent that's what
happened in at 1918 also mutation will
probably not account for a new wave soon
also it is possible a vaccine will most
likely protect reasonably well against
kovat 19 third the incubation period on
average nearly six days is roughly
roughly triple the average incubation
period of an of influenza that is ease
itself takes much longer for people to
recover from and stop shedding virus
from therefore even without social
distancing it would take months for the
outbreak to pass through a community as
opposed to six to ten weeks for
influenza with social distancing
necessary to reduce deaths by keeping
hospitals from being overwhelmed it will
take even longer
additionally the incubation period
allows an asymptomatic person more
opportunity to spread the disease now
I'm not sure about the stats they're the
reason I'm not sure about the stats is
because if the incubation period is
longer and if the disease vector is
longer and you are shutting
the virus and it's more infectious yes
it takes longer from beginning to end
for each person to get it and then clear
of it but also you're infecting three
times as many people so I'm not sure
that actually is much slower than the
flu statistically speaking but this guy
is is fairly sanguine he says the
country will have then have more time to
expand testing and contact tracing
isolating and quarantine contacts he
says we can't wait for her to immunity
to develop from natural infection that
would take many months and be
accompanied by an unaccompanied
unacceptable death toll nor can we wait
a year or more for that I've seen
instead we're talking about a phased in
approach okay so everybody at this point
is talking about a phased in approach
right I'm old enough to remember when
that was irresponsible where he got
ripped up and down from suggesting a
phased in approach where healthy people
go back to work first followed by people
who are more vulnerable that we continue
to wear masks and socially distancing
some people have been pushing that for
literally a month and a half among those
people like me but beyond that the
question becomes really this one
specific sub question which is should we
were masked and should we and should we
social distance I know this is now a
heretical question and I've been calling
for wearing masks and socially
distancing because again I would prefer
that if we're waiting for a therapeutic
or we are waiting for a vaccine and we
have not actually taken the measures
necessary to protect people who are
older and vulnerable that we should all
do our best to prevent the spread of the
infection to people who are older and
and who are more vulnerable and this
particularly true if you live with
somebody right the reason that I am
broadcasting from home and not going
into the office is not because I fear
for me or fair for my wife or for my
kids we are all thank God young and
healthy it's more because I fear for my
parents we're in their mid 60's but the
question becomes okay on a societal
level what should we do if nothing
changes over time so Scott Atlas from
Hoover Institute has a piece over at the
hill called how to reopen society using
medical science and logic and here is
what he suggests he says first
policymakers must apply logic and
critical thinking to the massive amount
of evidence we have acquired and combine
that with decades of established medical
science second we must demonstrate and
fully convey the logic underlying the
plan to reassure a public that has
become almost panelized paralyzed with
panic and fear so he says important to
note that most of the people who are
dying are people over 70 91 percent in
Michigan's Oakland County where people
over 60 similar to what was noted in New
York younger healthier people have
virtually zero risk of death little risk
of serious disease
1% of New York City's hospitalizations
were people under 18 years of age less
than 1% of deaths at any age are in the
absence of underlying conditions ok that
is not him suggesting that human lives
are not more valuable or at one age than
another or anything like that that is
him suggesting instead that we have to
translations and figure out whom to
protect and how we actually tranche back
in populations just like every other
person with a pre functioning brain has
been suggesting so here's what he
suggests he says let's finally focus
protection on the most vulnerable
nursing home patients already living
under controlled access this suit
includes strictly regulating all who
enter and care for nursing home members
by requiring testing and protective
masks for all who interact with these
highly vulnerable people we should
continue to inform the public about what
they have already successfully learned
regarding the at-risk group
this means issuing rational guidelines
advising the highest standards of
Hygiene and appropriate social
distancing while interacting with
elderly friends and family members at
risk including those with diabetes
obesity and other chronic conditions
second those with mild symptoms of the
illness should strictly self isolate for
two weeks it's not urgent to test them
simply assume they have the infection
that includes confinement at home having
the highest concern for sanitation and
wearing protective masks when others in
their home enter the same room third
open all the schools children have no
risk of serious illness from Kovac 19
exceptions exist but again standards for
consciously protecting elderly and other
at-risk family members of friends would
still be employed now here is where we
get the controversial section of what
Atlas is saying buried ok here's what he
says he says fourth open businesses
including restaurants and offices but
require new standards for hygiene
disinfection and sanitation sanitization
yet enforceable more stringent
regulations than in the past it is
reasonable to post warrants for
customers who are older or in other ways
vulnerable avoid unnecessary
requirements for spacing of customers
though it is not logical that otherwise
healthy adults especially younger age
groups should be isolated or maintain a
six-foot spacing from each other if
infection is still prevalent socializing
among these low risk groups represents
the opportunity for developing
widespread immunity and eradicating the
threat public transportation should
resume regional authorities could
require barrier masks for passengers
parks and beaches should open there's no
scientific reason to insist that people
remain indoors
finally implement implement prioritize
testing for three groups nursing home
workers health care workers and first
responders and patients in
hospitals widespread testing is not a
predicate for reopening contact tracing
is not valuable after a disease is
already widespread even though it would
be an important part of the overall
preparation for future potential
outbreaks okay so Atlas is actually kind
of saying we should be aiming for her to
mmunity and this is what Sweden is done
in Sweden has basically suggested we are
going to allow you if you're young and
healthy to go out and socialize with
others they'd recommend it social
distancing but you can see from the
pictures that people are not in fact
social distancing nearly as much people
are advised to keep apart and work from
home if possible to stay inside if aged
over 70 and to avoid unnecessary travel
but people have basically been going
around and doing what they want and as
time goes on people are not gonna want
to wear masks people are not going to
want to socially distance from each
other forever people are just not built
for any of this so are we aiming for
hurt immunity or are we not and that
really requires more data on whether
there's a therapeutic that is in the
works and we need to wait for three
weeks or we need to wait for two months
or waiting till the end of the year
right that is the big question and so
the balanced approach that I have sort
of been recommending is that we get back
to work if you're young and healthy
particularly that you that you do wear
the mask that we do aim to slow the
spread of the disease we don't aim for
herd immunity specifically we aim to buy
time until there is a vaccine but that
is based on people continually saying
that we might be able to ramp this thing
up by September or ramp this thing up by
the end of the year if we're talking 12
to 18 months if we're talking two years
as some people suggest then the notion
that we are going to be able to hold
down the spread for two years is just
bizarre it's not going to happen at that
point you really should just basically
tell everybody who's most vulnerable you
need to stay home you need to isolate
them you need to keep them protected and
then you need to tell people who are
young that they need to go out and
achieve herd immunity seriously if
you're talking to three years five years
and some people have been suggesting
then that essentially is the only option
and we can pretend there are other
options but there are not tons of other
options now it is also possible that
this thing starts to wane a little bit
as time goes on we just don't know
because nobody is that far ahead of us
to be able to determine this and we have
seen some spikes in places that are a
little bit ahead of us places like China
suffice it to say that a lot of the
measures that have been assumed to have
been slowing this thing down however
have actually been overkill and this is
where we get
the question as to why people should
have been laws that are clearly not
designed to actually prevent the spread
of the disease I mean yesterday for
example in my neighborhood there were
helicopters flying around and signing
and firing their sirens off at people
who are not socially distancing outside
and let's be frank about this the number
of people who are going to get infected
outside is way lower than the number of
people who are going to be infected
inside also the notion that California
is doing this right is ridiculous they
they there was a video that was going
around of Huntington Beach and you can
actually see the helicopters going
around and yelling at people on
Huntington Beach to socially distance
well there were no people on Huntington
Beach okay Huntington Beach was empty by
state order yesterday do we have that
video there's a yeah you can see okay
there's this helicopter flying around
and if you can hear the sound they're
actually announcing two people over
loudspeakers that we want you to
socially distance now look at the beach
there's no one on it there's no one on
it so we are wasting taxpayer dollars to
send a helicopter to tell an empty beach
that people needs a socially distance
there are no human beings there none
none zero zip zilch no humans none this
is idiotic meanwhile the NYPD is
announcing that they're going to start
enforcing at the ban that they are
passed the points of warnings when it
comes to social distancing I understand
that I'm just wondering why you idiots
didn't shut down the subway system weeks
ago if you actually want to prevent the
spread here and get some more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
sleep quality so it's harder and hard to
sleep these days mints is all very very
stressful that means that when you lie
down on a mattress the last thing you
want to be thinking about is the fact
you've got a creaky old mattress that
crappy old box spring that you've been
sleeping on for years instead you need a
mattress made for you so I'm at helix
sleep helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper hot
sleeper anything like a pleasure from
bed with helix there's no more confusion
and no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine CNN has called it the
most comfortable mattress they have ever
slept on just go to helix sleep calm
slash men take their two-minute sleep
quiz they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life I'll have a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights at risk free they'll even pick it
up for you
you don't love it but you will
uncomfortable mattress is everything
when you go to sleep it really has to be
it for you has made for your body type I
have one - I took the helix sleep quiz
been sleeping on a helix sleep mattress
for at least a couple of years now it is
just phenomenal
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders for my listeners get
up to $200 off at helix sleep comm /ban
again that's helix sleep dot-com / Ben
helix sleep comm slash man go check them
out right now
all righty we're gonna get some more of
this in just one second first time is
running out for you to get that second
left this chairs tumbler that's right
when you become a daily wire insider
plus we're all access member you get a
second leftist cheers tumbler oh look at
this all the power that flows through me
when I hold to left is tears tumblers
the tumblers are literally overflowing
with tears that thought of the software
ending but for our existing members it
is natural to feel a little jealous
don't worry we have a special offer
coming up just for you daily wire
members get many amazing benefits
including of course the singular leftist
ears tumblr you also get an ad-free
website experience access to all of our
live broadcast in show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
access to the mailbag and now exclusive
election insight editorials from La
David where members also get to ask us
questions during backstage and our
all-access members get to participate in
all access live it's our brand-new
interactive programming featuring one of
us one of us daily Waterhouse's we hang
out with you each night at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific this amazing deal
is ending tomorrow hurry become an
Insider plus or all-access member double
the tears with two leftist ears tumblers
that's daily wire calm / subscribe to
get started and get 10% off with our
coupon code Shapiro again that that
brand new all-access live is now
available only for all access members
you actually have to pay for that go to
daily wear now calm / subscribe coupon
code Shapiro do not wait or you will
miss out you're listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so basically the big question that
I'm asking here is the question of how
long we can continue to avoid most of
the activities of regular life without
supreme data that that's actually
helping too much it is one thing to say
that we don't want people willy-nilly
infecting each other and again even that
question is now on the table because
seriously we have to wonder if nothing
changes over the next couple of years
and if we are aiming for herd immunity
over time is that better than aiming for
herd immunity as quickly as possible
like Sweden was doing right Sweden was
was slowing the spread somewhat but not
too much since they now have Stockholm
like 40 percent penetration rate of this
of this disease so the question becomes
okay do you want the spike cap and now
or would you like the spike to happen
later and that's what people are
beginning to realize okay but if the
choice is between that or responsibly
social distancing or complete lock downs
then complete lock downs really should
not be on the table these complete lock
downs are not useful the complete lock
downs do not have an endpoint they do
not have a logical endpoint because
again nobody has yet really suggested
the vaccine is gonna be a little
tomorrow or a therapeutic will be
available tomorrow that allows us to all
go back to our lives so you're starting
to see mayor's hypocritical mayor's
actually going out and saying we're
gonna arrest you if you don't socially
distancing if you don't socially a
distance no I get it
I do I get I get arresting people Lori
Lightfoot also was disobeying her own
orders in Chicago to go get haircuts in
the middle of the pandemic and then
proclaiming that as mayor it's very
important to get a haircut here was Lori
Lightfoot suggesting that people would
be arrested in Chicago we will shut you
down
we will cite you and if we need to we
will arrest you and we will take you to
jail period there should be nothing
unambiguous about that don't make us
treat you like a criminal but if you act
like a criminal and you violate the law
and you refuse to do what is necessary
to save lives in the city in the middle
of a pandemic we will take you to jail
period okay now all of that is well and
good unless what you're talking about is
people just going to a park if we're
talking about is it like really if
you're talking about one of those big
social gatherings of a thousand people
infecting each other in downtown Chicago
or something in the south side of
Chicago which is what we were seeing a
couple of weeks ago fair enough
now do you have a problem with
de Blasio arresting people in mass
gatherings although it's weird that he
would single out just the Jews in his
tweets a lot of people were doing that
sort of stuff but the idea that the the
NYPD's gonna come break it up or that
Lori Lightfoot is gonna come break it up
that's fine but that changes that math
changes when you start looking at
ridiculous shutdown orders of public
places like beaches or parks that's what
we've seen in California instead how
about this how about we actually engage
in data-driven methods that are meant to
reopen to the extent that people can
actually live with it at least for a
certain amount of time
Rhonda Sanchez over in Florida for
example he's been ripped up and down
why because Rhonda's hands didn't shut
down Florida fast enough there's a
little one problem the results in
Florida are not bad Florida's doing
about the same as California you know in
Rhonda's Hansons didn't do didn't shut
down the entire city I mean the entire
state he didn't he said big cities are
gonna have to shut down mostly smaller
places not so much here was governor de
santis who's ripped you remember the the
media coverage endlessly was about how
evil Ron de santis was for not
preemptively shutting the state the
beaches are full spring break oh my god
people are gonna they're all young none
of those people were gonna die or at
least very few of those people are gonna
die and Rhonda Sanchez his state is
basically fine here was Rhonda census
yesterday explaining his approach to
this thing the only thing we have to
fear is letting fear overwhelm our sense
of purpose and determination we need to
focus on facts and not fear and I think
that there's been a lot that's been done
to try to promote fear we were told over
and over again Florida was going to be
just like New York when it came to the
corona virus well let's look at the tale
of the tape how close were we to New
York fatalities obviously a much
different picture okay and he is correct
about that obviously the census also
explained that he is going to set up
mobile RV labs so that they are going to
be able to to check out old-age homes
which of course is sort of what Scott
Atlas is suggesting right that what we
have to do is mainly focus on protecting
the most vulnerable populations here as
DeSantis again why distanc is became the
criminal here is is pretty incredible
the stanzas became the credible criminal
because he's a Republican in the in the
view of the media but guess what his
fate
fine here's the Santa's I'm gonna be
unveiling a mobile RV lab that we can
drive across Florida the results are
going to come back in 45 minutes so
we're going to go to nursing homes is
going to be our number one thing test
the staff test the residents and
eventually Maria once we get enough pet
rapid test I'd like to be able to test
the family members and let them go visit
their loved ones these people haven't
had visitors for close to two months
that's not an easy thing obviously we
gotta err on the side of safety but if a
son or daughter can get a test and
they're there they're negative then they
should be able to go in and see see
their parents so what exactly did the
Santa's do the wall street journal has a
piece today called smart or lucky how
Florida dodged the worst of coronavirus
when the man when the corona virus
pandemic swept toward Florida public
health professionals nationally warned
of a potentially devastating wave of
infections that could imperil the
state's large senior population but so
far the state seems to have dodged that
fate despite not following advice to
impose measures such as an early blanket
lockdown to minimize spread so what
exactly happened to Santa's restricted
visitation to nursing homes but he left
early lockdown decisions to local
authorities mayors in some hard-hit
large communities shut down faster and
more aggressively than the state gaining
valuable time Walt Disney World closed
two weeks before the statewide order
Spring Breakers went back home some
scientists point to Florida's low
population density others to its
subtropical climate to explain fewer
infections though the governor did not
impose a statewide stay-at-home order
until April 3rd people began hunkering
down on mass in mid-march
according to firms that analyzed
anonymous cell phone data that was
around the same time deaths in the u.s.
topped 100 and residents of New York
started staying home the state needs to
double its current volume of testing to
more than 32,000 tests a day to detect
and respond to flare-ups says Charles
Lockwood the Dean of University of South
Florida more sandy College of Medicine
that will take about a month as of
Saturday Florida had more than 35,000
cases of kovat 19 the disease caused by
the new corona virus in late March a
model developed by the Institute for
Health metrics and evaluation at UW was
predicting nearly 7,000 deaths in the
state by August a figure the modeler
said could shift depending on adherence
to social modeling Florida has six
deaths per 100,000 people as compared to
42 in Louisiana 56 in Massachusetts 97
in New York California had 5 deaths per
100,000 people Texas had 3 so maybe it
turns out that local leaders have the
best view of this stuff
that local leaders actually did what
they were supposed to do in their local
communities that individual human beings
are risk averse and smart enough to
recognize that they're going to have to
avoid risk the notion that the DeSantis
did something totally wrong by allowing
local officials to have their way is
just ridiculous he is not wrong about
this in fact it was a better data-driven
program than a lot of what was happening
statewide like New York State upstate
New York should not have shut down New
York City should have shut down place it
California you think central California
should have shut down there's nobody in
central California right in LA is very
spread out LA shouldn't completely shut
down we should have socially distance
and maybe in downtown LA but even there
the population density isn't that high
in San Francisco you do a shutdown and
then you let people back out again New
York City is not like other places New
Orleans is not like other places Detroit
is not like other places and treating
all those places like places within the
state is idiotic treating Philadelphia
like the suburban and rural areas
outside of Philadelphia is ridiculous
that's not data driven you want to know
why DeSantis didn't get crushed his
hands didn't get crushed because people
basically did the responsible thing you
know what you want no I New York got
crushed because New York is New York
that's why New York got crushed yes
there was some miss handling I pointed
out the miss handling but in the end we
are drawing closer and closer to the
reality of the situation which is going
to be that if nothing happens in the
near future what all we can do all we
can do is protect the most vulnerable
people in our population and then let
everybody else go back to work and we
have to determine what percentage of
those people are actually vulnerable and
what presenters are not one of the
things we've heard is the question it's
a serious question what percentage of
Americans are actually vulnerable Mike
seriously vulnerable if you go by
population I'm gonna look it up right
now the population statistics in the
United States of us by age the
population of the United States by age
there are about 15 to 19 there are about
let's see the population of the United
States there are about 20 million people
who are under the age of five we really
start to balloon out at age 55 plus
total you're talking about a let's eat
20 million there you're talking
somewhere in the neighborhood of 45 to
50 million people who are above the age
of 60 in the United States
and then you have to figure out how many
of the remaining population are people
who have pre-existing conditions like
obesity or diabetes but once you figure
that out then you have to determine
who's healthy and if that healthy pot
let's say that healthy population let's
say the healthy population of the United
States is somewhere in the neighborhood
of 50 to 60 percent okay well if all
those people get infected and none of
those people die which is basically what
komen 19 is doing if you're young and
healthy or not dying from this link then
you have to start thinking about how
close are we actually to hurt immunity
what are the possibility but the
possibilities for herd immunity and I
know these have been verboten words
we're not supposed to say herd immunity
anymore but what do you think a vaccine
is so either vaccine is gonna do it or
your natural immunity is going to do it
and the question is is one of those
things possible and it's one of those
things not possible meanwhile one of the
reasons why people are a little doubtful
about these statewide lockdown orders is
it seems like there's a wide Quinn a
wild coincidence in which all of the
places that are locking down most
harshly are also eager to push
world-changing social policies we'll get
to that in just a minute
first it's time for things I like and
some things that I hate so things that I
like over the weekend I read another
Robert Harris now this guy's great he
wrote a novel called an officer and a
spy it is about the Dreyfus Affair
for folks you don't know the Dreyfus
Affair the Dreyfus Affair was a
situation in which a French high ranking
officer named Alfred Dreyfus is back in
the late 19th century was accused of
spying on behalf of the Germans it turns
out that the evidence had been
completely not only wrong but the
evidence had been actually made up by
high-ranking intelligence officials in
order to convict the guy the this book
is a very well grounded historical novel
about the detective who figured that out
and then basically revealed that
evidence to the public drivers had been
put on Devil's Island for four years he
spent four years on Devil's Island by
himself alone pegged as a traitor it
turns out it was another officer in the
army because the Dreyfus was Jewish
there was a lot of momentum for keeping
him there and people basically were
willing to blame the Jews I mean this is
this the the Dreyfus Affair was largely
responsible for the rise of the Zionist
movement in Europe because France which
was considered one of the most cultured
countries in Europe had masses of people
out in the streets shouting death to the
Jews because of Dreyfus and led Theodor
Herzl who was at that point a a fairly
secular Jew to say to himself hold
a second I think the Jews might need
their own country here because every
time this guy was a loyal Army officer
and he was humiliated in front of the
entire French National Army and then he
was sent to Devil's Island and then
people were chanting death to the Jews
even as it became obvious that the
government had not only covered up his
innocence but had actually manufactured
the evidence in the first place
it's an amazing story it's really well
told by Robert Harris I mentioned that
they've made a movie out of this Roman
Polanski made a movie out of this
apparently the movies really good but
we'll never get to see it because Roman
Polanski's a bad bad man he is in fact a
bad man he's been convicted of child
rape in the United States but I'm just
wondering why it is that the people in
Hollywood were cheering him when he won
an Oscar for The Pianist but now we
can't see this movie because he's been
declared newly bad or what in any case
my general feeling about art and artists
as I mentioned last week is that if
you're a crappy person as an artist that
doesn't mean we shouldn't be able to see
your art already time for a bevy a
cornucopia a veritable panoply of things
I hate let's do it
alrighty so as I mentioned one of the
reasons that there is increasing
skepticism about the full lockdown
orders is because of the dishonesty of
the media and because of the political
agenda of some of the people pushing
this thing it seems like there are
people who are rooting hard against
Sweden rooting hard against places that
are opening up if they want those places
to fail you just get this underlying
sense from people in the media they
would love to see Georgia fall on its
face they would love to see Florida fall
on its face
they want to see Texas fall on its face
and not because they want to see more
dead people but because they want to see
Republican governors humiliated for not
taking coronavirus seriously enough what
they should be doing is ruining that
this thing is not as deadly as we have
been told this thing is well under 1%
they should be rooting that it doesn't
pass as easily or that the summer kills
it off or that we can get back to
regularly I mean I wouldn't care who's
president I'm rooting to go back to
regular life but you do get the feeling
that there are some people who are a
little bit too sanguine about exactly
how these lockdowns are going and
they're looking for an excuse in order
to keep the lockdowns going in order so
that they can promulgate policies that
they wanted in the first place and that
is how this becomes a political issue if
we were all doing data driven analyses
then as I say what you want to know
what's what's so fascinating about all
of this look at the purple states don't
look at the red states don't look at the
blue states look at the purple states
the purple states are the ones that are
fascinating Abbott
is going to be in in Texas more freedom
oriented DeSantis in Florida's gonna be
more freedom freedom oriented Newsome in
California very blue state he's gonna be
significantly non freedom oriented in
New York Cuomo is gonna be significantly
non freedom oriented then look to some
of the purple states Colorado is a
purple state what's happening in
Colorado starting to open up Montana is
a red state with a blue governor rights
Bullock is the governor of Montana just
ran for president if you recall that
five minutes Bullock has kept the state
open throughout Maine is a purple state
Maine is reopening Minnesota is a purple
state Tim Walz the governor of Minnesota
is a Democrat he's reopening interesting
how the purple states are starting to
reopen it's one of the reasons why sort
of the hot spots of these debates are
happening in purple states happening in
Wisconsin happening in Michigan
happening in Pennsylvania because this
is where the rubber hits the road
governors who are who are in those
purple states are under pressure and the
reason they're under pressure is because
there are a lot of people saying we
don't want to see a fundamental change
in our society come about as a result of
Kovan 19 meanwhile in California which
is totally blue people are like well now
lockdowns maybe we can do something
magical with that tim Arango and thomas
full of writing for the new york times
after the virus california liberals have
returning to normal won't be enough oh
who couldn't see this one coming
that's right every crisis and
opportunity Dateline Los Angeles housing
for the homeless criminal justice reform
addressing the digital divide for
schoolchildren in rural areas propelled
by the urgency of the coronavirus crisis
and despite severe economic headwinds
liberal Californians see this moment as
an opening to push through an agenda
that addresses some of the state's most
intractable and long debated problems
hey can I be real about the housing for
the homeless issue drive around LA the
only people you'll see on the streets of
the homeless ok literally every
underpass still has homeless people
living under it in close coordination
and the only and the only reason that
they are not there is because they're
being physically rousted by the police
because the police are finally being
allowed to do what they should have been
allowed to do all along which is rouse
people who are living in public areas so
this is the the pitch by the media is
that the reason the homeless are off the
streets is because of the housing made
available for the homeless that is not
why the homeless are off the streets
the reason the homeless are off the
streets is because the police are
telling them that if they do not get off
the streets they will be physically put
into places like these hotels anyway
thousands of people have been let out of
the state's jails and prisons cash bail
has been eliminated for most crimes
thousands of homeless people now have
roofs over their heads they're being
threatened and children in rural and
poor areas of the state are being sent
tens of thousands of laptop computers
for distance learning temporary measures
to confront the pandemic that leaders
are hoping will become durable solutions
to long-standing problems of inequity oh
there it is we're gonna use this crisis
okay can can I point something out the
laptops being sent to these rural
communities
I'm homeschooling my kids if parents
aren't doing responsible schooling in
the presence of schools what makes you
think that when you homeschool the kids
the parents are sitting there every
minute of every day making sure the kids
are learning really is there any
evidence that sending kids home from
schools has somehow rectified
educational and equity if you send them
a laptop I've seen no evidence that if
you send a kid home with an iPad and the
real problem in education is the kids
home environment that the iPad has
magically changed things meanwhile many
in the country talk about returning to
normal but a common refrain is emerging
among California's powerful political
left-wing and many liberal leaders
across America normal wasn't working
well weird because you guys have been
running the state my entire lifetime
whether you're talking about
homelessness whether you're talking
about criminal justice system and
incarceration we're doing things today
that should've been done that a long
time ago said George Gascon on a former
San Francisco district attorney now
running for the same office in LA he's
been at the vanguard of a national
movement of prosecutors looking to
reduce mass incarceration so we're gonna
let all the criminals out of prison we
are going to round up the homeless and
put them in hotels and we are going to
send kids laptops and this is California
shifting its positions in the middle of
the crisis yet buried in paragraph eight
grand ambitions are also coming up
against stark realities though
California is deeply blue with Democrats
holding all the top offices and a
supermajority in the legislature the
state has failed for decades to tackle
some of the biggest issues surrounding
inequality I like how that sentence is
phrased though California is deeply blue
no because California is deeply blue the
state has failed for decades to tackle
some of the biggest issues surrounding
inequality because it's deeply blue
because these leftist policies are
failures because taxing people and then
spending lots of money does not actually
rectify inequality you morons by one
measure California has the nation's
highest poverty rate some Californians
whether the will to enact significant
change
will endure past the initial stage of
coronavirus crisis I love that the state
that's been permanently blue basically
my entire adult lifetime is now saying
will we have the will to change this
thing afterward but you want to know why
I have some serious doubts about why
exactly Gavin Newsom is going so
overboard shutting down Huntington Beach
and sending helicopters to yell at sand
it's because of articles like this one
Newsom says it's the spirit of our times
what often takes a year now we MIT we
need to do in months in Los Angeles Eric
Garcetti has proposed using the crisis
as a catalyst to achieve free higher
education and mitigate inequality
he says the shock to our economy and our
lives recalls the scale and the
challenges faced by the generation who
sacrificed through the Great Depression
and World War two yeah the Great
Depression was length in eight years by
bad government policy and world war two
had an external enemy that required us
to send people to barracks and to risk
their lives against bullets and and
bombs in order to kill Nazis and in
order to kill members of the Japanese
Imperial Army by the way it's not just
happening at the state level Nancy
Pelosi is taking advantage of all of
this in order to grab power according to
Bradley Byrne over at The Wall Street
Journal
he says for nearly two months my staff
and I have been fielding calls from the
people of South West Alabama small
business owners bank or seniors and many
others the government's response to
coronavirus is affecting their
livelihoods their congressman may be the
only voice they have in Washington but
when the lights are turned off in
committee rooms and on the floor of the
house who's watching out for them who's
holding Washington accountable more
important than the flawed message
Congress's absence sends to the American
people that their representatives value
personal protection is the reality when
nobody is around it is easier to make
backroom deals and speaker Pelosi is
taking advantage she has consolidated
the power of the institution in her
person without lawmakers there to speak
up for their districts and influence the
legislative process Pelosi has made
herself the sole voice and negotiator
for the house as a passives massive
funding and regulatory builds her mode
of operating is crystal clear once the
speaker feels she has gained maximum
concessions from Trump she calls the
house back to Washington to be quickly
and quietly herded into chamber to cast
an up-or-down vote bypassing committees
markups in every process that gives
lawmakers a voice in other words she's
taking advantage Bern is a Republican in
Alabama's first congressional district
and meanwhile taking advantage our
ideological warriors of the left Court
this pandemic in order to claim that
America is racist sexist bigoted
homophobic etc etc Charles blow the
aptly-named Charles blow over the New
York Times has a piece today titled
kovat 19 race and class warfare you know
because like the virus kills lots of
people who are not poor and it's a virus
and it doesn't know whether you're rich
or poor because it only attacks you your
body but according to Charles blow again
it's because America is evil for the
thousandth time the reason that people
yeah III ask whether the law isn't asked
the reason I ask whether the law isn't
asked is because there are only a few
reasons why people are going to pay the
law one is the law is good right the law
is beneficial the reason that you obey
laws because the law is beneficial if
the law is not beneficial there are only
two other reasons you would obey the law
one you hope for some reward to you risk
some punishments but as the American
people realize that perhaps the reward
of going back to work is better than the
punishment I'm not going back to work
they're just gonna go back to work and
the government threatening punishment
for laws that are unenforceable and
stupid is not going to result in people
obeying the laws and if I believe that
your law is designed specifically in
order to undermine the free markets that
have brought the world from the brink of
starvation to the brink of prosperity if
that's what I think your agenda is I'm
not going to obey your law your law is
garbage and the only thing that will
keep me obeying the law is your threat
of punishment no one wants to die nobody
is interested in passing this on to a
parent at a certain point the reason
that DeSantis is right in Florida and
Abbott is right in Texas because you're
gonna have to trust the American people
and I know the media been doing not
picking and going around and finding
people who are crazy or socially who are
not socially distancing and spinning all
over each other and partying it up the
reality is most Americans particularly
those who care about the vulnerable are
staying away from each other but this is
not this is not changing the underlying
math so blow has this entire piece about
how America's evil now quick note I have
a book that is coming out July 21st
called how to destroy America in three
easy steps we've released the cover it
is all about this it is all about how
there is a segment of American society
that wishes to see America as evil she's
our philosophy as evil sees the founding
American philosophy as evil she's our
culture of rights as merely cover for a
caste hierarchy that sees our history as
an unending series of abuses and these
folks are using this pandemic as an
excuse to simply
double down on that position blow is one
of those she says people mostly white
sometimes armed occasionally carrying
Confederate flags or hosting placards
emblazoned with the Nazi slogan from the
Holocaust
I've been plowed Lee protesting to push
their state governments to reopen
business and spaces before enough
progress has been made to contain the
coronavirus this has yet another
illustration of the race and class
divide this pandemic has illuminated in
this country
for some a reopened economy and
recreational landscape will mean the
option to run a business return to work
go to the park or Beach have a night on
the town in a nice restaurant or swanky
bar but many on the lower rungs of the
economic ladder
it will only force them back into a
compulsory exposure to more people often
in occupations that make it hard to
protect oneself and that pay little for
the risk okay this is such absolute
sheer insanity first of all to suggest
that everybody who's protesting is
carrying a confederate flag or hoisting
placards with Nazi slogans and we've
talked to some of the people that these
protests that is not what is happening
here and also the notion that if you're
on the lower rungs of the economic
ladder at your best interest lies in the
government picking up the check for you
as opposed to you having a job is again
total insanity the people who are losing
their jobs are disproportionately
blue-collar workers many of whom are
disproportionately minority and those
people need their jobs back and many of
them want to work and want to work in
safe conditions we would all like to
work in safe conditions but if you if
you have an underlying pre-existing
condition there's nothing that you can
do about that other than stay home and
for those people we should be
encouraging those people to stay home
and maybe we should be talking about how
this virus has created a necessity for a
broader social safety net not
necessarily even from the government but
from private charity but according to
Charles blow this is all about the evils
of the white infrastructure again all in
a quoi all in equality in the view of
the left is inequity all inequality is
is evidence of America's root system the
reason for this is because the Left
believes that human beings are
infinitely malleable that all situations
are infinitely malleable and if you get
the economics just right through
redistribution then everybody becomes
perfect and everybody has an equal
outcome not true never will be true but
the fact that inequality is a permanent
condition of human life
means that the cat the the quest to
destroy the entire superstructure will
continue apace Charles blow says these
are the struggling workers who entertain
and esvet anesthetized people of means
these businesses were
I know means a sessional essential and
they put these workers in danger he's
talking about tattoo parlors barbershops
Hair Salons and nail shops I have a
question why were they not essential
because Charles blow says they're not
essential you know one of the things I
noticed customers were showing up
particularly customers were showing up
in minority communities read the Atlanta
journal-constitution
the Atlanta journal-constitution made
clear there were actual racial divides
in the number of people showing up to
barber shops and nail salons through
personal choice not because they're
being forced to go out there customers
and many of the people doing these jobs
as Charles blow will have to take public
transit to get to work search for
suitable childcare before they leave
home schools in most cases are still
closed but even among professions we
don't immediately consider low-wage or
minority dominated there are areas of
high risk and low wages for many the
image that comes to mind about the
medical field those on the front lines
are doctors and nurses people highly
educated and highly paid but there are
many other people in the hospitals that
make them run for instance a majority of
nursing assistants are members of racial
minority groups 1/3 or african-american
half of completed no formal education
beyond high school
according to register nursing the median
annual wage for a nursing assistant in
the hospital is just 30 grand ok so so I
mean really so I I don't understand how
that has to do with societal racism
maybe those are people who are
attempting to work their way up the job
ladder good for them good for them those
are heroes and to meaning them to the
level of victims of American racism
because they're going in and being
heroic is wild blow says it's been
widely reported the virus is having a
disproportionate impact on black and
brown people in America both in terms of
infections and death but that is only
one aspect of the disparities in a
country or race and ethnicity often
intersects with wealth and class they're
a cascade of other impacts particularly
economic ones to remain conscious of
reality of the situation the virus is
not targeting black and brown people the
virus is targeting people who have
diabetes obesity asthma the virus is
targeting people based on health
condition that tends to overlap with
poverty and that tends to overlap with
race some of that is the result of
historic injustice in the United States
a huge part of that has nothing to do
with the historic and justices of the
United States historic wealth gaps have
been rectified by many different racial
groups in the United States the question
is
how fast that is happening and whether
the rules that are currently in place
are conducive to that happening but
again the goal for a lot of people is to
use the pandemic as the latest evidence
that America is deeply evil today not
was evil back in the 1960s with Jim Crow
is evil today and this must be torn down
around our ears and then you wonder why
people are bucking the system and saying
maybe we don't trust your motivations
and keeping this thing closed maybe we
don't trust your motivations and
avoiding the data all right we'll be
back here later two additional hours we
will get to everything Joe Biden related
then because Joe Biden has a serious
problem on his hands we'll get to that a
little bit later today otherwise we'll
see you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
why douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]